mr. president welcome back to the
program tell you much I kill him thank
you very much good to see you
things seem quite different than they
did last year in the year before what
will happen do you think if President
Trump pulls the United States out of the
nuclear deal jcpoa jcpoa a multilateral
agreement ratified by the United Nations
Security Council exiting such an
agreement would have very high cost for
the United States of America and I do
not believe that Americans would be
willing to pay such a high cost for
something that will be useless for them
it will yield no results for the United
States but at the same time it will
generally decrease and cut away and chip
away at international trust placed in
the United States of America what would
you do what would Iran do options at our
disposal visibly this issue if the
United States pulls out of the jcpoa
there has been a great deal of thought
given to this possible scenario
regarding our reaction and if such a
thing were to happen quite swiftly the
world will see Iran's steps and
reactions this action will take place in
a matter of a few days however given
that mr. Drumm reactions and actions and
policies are somewhat unpredictable we
have had long thought and discussions
about our reactions can I ask you
because I've talked to other Iranian
government officials I've spoken to
officials from around the world what do
you think of President Trump's Twitter
diplomacy do you see a strategy do you
see policy do see chaos what what do you
see do you
well in any way it is a method that
Mister footage trump has started he
knows better than anyone he wishes
perhaps to enter into certain
announcements actively and the head of
the media I don't see it as a problem
specifically however what he reads at
certain points doesn't seem to be in
accordance and in line with other
statements from other American officials
and this by its nature causes a certain
deal of chaos you see what's happening
between Burma Myanmar and Bangladesh
Rakhine State the RO hinder minority the
Moslems being being thrown out of
Myanmar
what is Iran's position on this and how
dangerous is it in terms of it being yet
another cause yet another Muslim cause
for the terrorists to use as an excuse
to create more terrorism around the
world you read kam Sagara recent
developments are fairly unprecedented
under which 400,000 people have been run
from their home and their house is set
oblate by the Myanmar security forces so
it is a human tragedy and it is a
genocide that is taking place and I
believe that not only Muslims but all
countries from throughout the world must
visa vide the Myanmar government and
then Myanmar Armed Forces stand
steadfast against their current actions
and render great deal of support and aid
to the refugees currently entering
Bangladesh is it a magnet to recruit
terrorists hami chingu naked Ahmad these
actions oppression against people
running them from their homes genocides
always lay the grounds for extremism and
violence and it is possible for
terrorists to wish to use such an
atmosphere and
such a foundation but it is up to us to
not allow them to use these four to use
these as tools to draw people as a
magnet and certainly once their defeat
is ultimately achieved and driven from
seed the Syrian and Iraqi battlefield
they would certainly focus elsewhere and
it is of great danger not only for us
but the rest of the world as well as
Europe of course what is your reaction
to the leader of North Korea Kim jong-un
with his sixth nuclear test with his
ICBM missile test with sending missiles
over Japan threatening American
territory what is your reaction to
what's happening there right now and he
has nuclear weapons
Massimo Phoolan Raja Basilicata our
position has been very clear and remains
clear visa vie nuclear weapons we are
against any type of weapons of mass
destruction as well as nuclear weapons
and we believe that they must be
destroyed throughout the world
so our opinion our positions are clear
arms races are not acceptable to us in
any region and we see that as extremely
dangerous however from the other side
the positions and the actions of the
United States as well as other nations
against the North Korean countries has
not been very positive and I don't think
there is a military solution to this
only diplomacy is the tool that will
resolve this problem permanently a
security adviser to the president of
South Korea told me that if the Obama
administration had spent one fifth of
the time it spent with you and Iran on
North Korea's nuclear program it may
have had some success
it hasn't spent any time very little
time has been spent trying to make a
deal with North Korea all over our whole
creation anyways North Korea was on
tract of talks and dialogue and those
roads were blocked and both sides chose
non dialogue actions and I think what
the Iranian experience shows is a good
experience that can be replicated
elsewhere and executed elsewhere but
keep in mind please that if the United
States wishes to withdraw from the Joye
jcpoa why would the North Koreans waste
their time in order to sit around the
table of dialogue with the United States
because they will think that perhaps
after years of talks and a potential
agreement the next US administration
could step over a pool out of the
agreement achieved so the Trump
administration such action or such
potential action but the Trump
administration will block such potential
roads to success in resolution of
regional problems around the world
President Trump will make his first
address to the United Nations tomorrow
on on Tuesday
he's expected to talk a lot about Iran
as well as North Korea and other issues
but a lot about Iran what do you expect
to hear and if you were to meet
President Trump what would you say to
him we can talk the way in which
currently in which does for the US
administration has chosen to stand
against Iran and the jcpoa has been the
wrong one and the proof has been
experienced by previous administrations
in the United States and the conclusion
is natural to reach that what the Obama
administration is in order to achieve
success in this engagement visa vita
jcpoa and iran drew upon the
unsuccessful unsuccessful experiences of
previous administrations however the
path undertaken today by this US
administration is a return to the past
to a distant past that goes all the way
back to President Bush number one as
well as President Bush the son number
two
so these
have already been traveled upon they
have been unsuccessful and soon that mr.
Trump will see that this was the wrong
path that he had chosen on that note mr.
president thank you very much indeed for
joining us man how much richer I'm also
thankful grateful for being here thank
you